- [Narrator] This is Howard,
he's four months old.
He lives in California with his family.
Tuk is his mom.
Domino is his dad, and Boo is his sister.
They are pileated gibbons.
(lively, bouncy music)
This species is found in
Thailand, Cambodia, and Laos.
In the wild, they are threatened
by habitat destruction
and the wild animal trade.
They live mostly in trees and all gibbons
have strong arms and legs.
The long, muscular arms help them move
through the branches
with impressive speed.
Romantics by nature,
pileated gibbon couples
are usually monogamous, often staying
with their partners for life.
Gibbon couples form strong
bonds, grooming each other
and hanging out in trees.
Both males and females are similar in size
and have a cooperative family dynamic.
Families do everything together,
and when the children are grown,
they leave to create their own families.
Baby gibbons learn how to
grasp their mother's hair
from early on, and will
nurse for the first
two years of their life.
Howard hasn't started
swinging on his own yet,
but he'll be ready to start learning soon.
This is the pileated gibbon.
(chiming note)